-While the Biden administration
is doing everything possible
to counter Russia's invasion
of Ukraine,
while avoiding a direct
military confrontation
that could spiral
out of control,
Republicans
and right-wing pundits
are pitching
increasingly reckless ideas
that would drastically
escalate the conflict.
Oh, and Donald Trump
is blaming it on windmills.
[ Laughter ]
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Russia's brutal and illegal
invasion of Ukraine
set off a dire
humanitarian crisis
and united virtually
the entire world in opposition.
Even fast food chains
are pulling their business
from Russia.
-Several more big-name
companies announced
they're ending at least part
of their operations in Russia.
McDonald's, Starbucks,
Coca-Cola,
Pepsi, KFC, Pizza Hut,
and Unilever
are scaling back
or ending their sales
of their product in Russia.
-Even Pizza Hut!
Putin tried to outpizza the Hut,
but he learned the hard way,
in Russia, Hut outpizzas you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And KFC, too.
KFC, too.
What a bummer for the
Russian Colonel Sanders,
or, as he's known in Russia...
[ Laughter and applause ]
So Russia lost its Pizza Hut
and KFCs
and, as a form
of further punishment,
a Sbarro's in Red Square
just opened.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There are no good outcomes
for anyone here,
including Russia.
The regime is
under intense sanctions
or, in the case of the Sbarro,
sbanctions,
[ Laughter ]
and facing nearly universal
global condemnation
and, on top of that,
they're encountering
brave resistance
from the Ukrainian people
and their president,
Volodymyr Zelenskyy,
who said,
in a new interview this week,
that this war can only end
with dialogue.
-Can you make a compromise
with Putin?
Can you trust Putin?
-Trust?
Oh, no.
I trust only my family.
-How can you make a deal
with somebody
you don't trust, then?
-We have to.
We have to.
Because, to stop this war,
how to stop this war?
Only dialogue.
-What would be your message
to President Vladimir Putin
right now?
-Right now?
Right now, stop the war,
begin to speak. That's it.
--And what if he doesn't?
-I think he will.
I think he will.
I think he sees
that we're strong.
He will.
-That's really incredible.
Even a guy who is being hunted
by one of the world's
most barbaric autocrats
still believes
in the power of dialogue.
And let's not forget --
this guy,
who is now courageously
leading his people
in defense of their homeland
was once Ukraine's top comedian,
[ Laughter ]
which makes it
even more incredible
because the comedians I know
do not believe in dialogue.
They believe in monologue.
[ Laughter ]
Every conversation
between my comedian friends
is just two people performing
at each other.
[ Laughter ]
And you know when one of them
says something funny
because the other one says,
"That's funny."
[ Laughter ]
Also, can we go back to this?
-Can you trust Putin?
-Trust?
Oh, no.
I trust only my family.
-I mean, that's even
more impressive to me
because I don't trust my family,
even a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
Especially my kids.
Couple of nights ago --
true story --
our oldest threw up,
so we brought him in bed with us
and we got him a bowl,
in case it happened again.
Twenty minutes later,
the three-year-old
started screaming
that he's also going to puke
and I said,
"I think you're faking it
and I think you just want
to get in bed with us, too."
And he said,
"No, I'm really, really sick."
So we got in bed,
he got his own bowl,
and tell me,
based on this photo,
if you think
he was telling the truth.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, while I know it can't be
easy to talk to Putin,
at least you don't have
to negotiate
with Axel at 3:00 am.
[ Laughter ]
The point is,
if even Zelenskyy still believes
in the power of dialogue,
then the rest of us should, too,
because he's right --
that's the only way
this horrific conflict can end.
Reckless escalation
will only make things worse,
which is why irresponsible
GOP politicians and pundits need
to stop floating crazy ideas
that would only heighten tension
between nuclear powers.
Like, for example, when we told
you earlier this week
that Donald Trump
had come up with an insane idea
to bomb Russia, but pretend
it was China that did it.
-According to CBS,
Trump says we should,
"Put the Chinese flag
on some F-22 fighter jets"
and "bomb the [bleep]
out of Russia."
[ Laughter ]
Now, Trump reportedly
made the suggestion
to top GOP donors at a retreat
in New Orleans this weekend.
The crowd apparently laughed
when he said this, so,
let's just assume it was a joke.
-No, let's not assume that.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, a lot of us assumed
that he was joking
when he said he was going
to run for president
because, you know, he was
a famously broke
game show idiot.
[ Laughter ]
But Trump is always joking,
until he's not.
He's like a husband
pitching a three-way
to his wife and her best friend.
[ Laughter ]
"I mean, that would be so funny,
the three of us, right?
Would it be funny?
Should we do it, though,
as a joke?"
[ Laughter ]
That's how Trump
gauges reaction,
by pretending he's not serious.
Remember when he was supposedly
joking, in 2016,
that Russia should hack
Hillary's emails
and then they actually did it?
Or when he looked one of his
science advisors dead in the eye
and suggested
we should inject people
with disinfectant
to cure coronavirus
and then later claimed
he was joking?
If that was a joke, then why
did her face look like that?
[ Laughter ]
She looks like she just heard
they opened a Sbarro in D.C.
[ Laughter ]
That's what Trump does --
he floats crazy [bleep]
and sees how far he can take it.
If one idea gets rejected,
he just tries another one.
[ As Trump ]
Alright, how about this?
Instead of putting
the Chinese flag on the jets,
we give them a fake nose
and a mustache.
[ Laughter ]
Or we stack three jets on top
of each other in a trench coat
and pretend they're
a businessman.
[ Laughter ]
Out-of-town businessman.
It could work.
Would that work?
Let's remember --
no one seriously thought
Trump would stage a coup,
either,
and then he ended up siccing
an angry mob of insurrectionists
and werewolves on the Capitol.
[ Laughter ]
Or how about Trump's obsession
with windmills?
You might think that's all
a big joke, too, but it's not.
He's still obsessed with them.
In fact, this week, Trump was
asked about the Russian invasion
and used it
as a jumping-off point
to start ranting incoherently,
once again,
about how much
he hates windmills.
-What do you see happening
next, then?
Because it seems like
the tensions are high.
How does this all end?
Is this going to be like
a long-term thing?
How do you see it unfolding?
-Well -- and I said this
a long time ago --
if this happens, we are
playing right into the hands
of green energy.
The windmills, they don't work.
[ Laughter ]
They're too expensive.
They kill all the birds.
They ruin your landscapes.
[ Laughter ]
And yet, the environmentalists
love the windmills.
And I've been preaching this
for years.
The windmills.
And I had them way down,
but the windmills
are the most expensive energy
you can have
and they don't work.
And, by the way,
they last a period of ten years
and, by the time
they start rusting and rotting
all over the place,
nobody ever takes them down.
They just go on to the next
piece of prairie or land
and destroy that.
-First of all, I feel like you
should like windmills
because you both just go
in [bleep] circles all the time
[ Laughter ]
and make a giant sucking sound.
I mean, seriously,
how does he get
from Russia's invasion
of Ukraine
to windmills in one sentence?
[ Laughter ]
Trump's favorite game is
One Degree of Windmills.
[ As Trump ]
Give me any topic and I'll tie
it to windmills in one move.
"Uh, I don't know.
Inflation."
[ As Trump ]
And, with inflation,
people are paying twice,
maybe three times
what they paid
for a windmill last year.
[ Laughter ]
I'm really good at it.
I'm really good
at One Degree of Windmills.
[ Laughter ]
This is the leader
of the Republican Party.
He's their most likely nominee
in 2024
and, whether he runs or not,
he still wields tremendous power
over the party.
Republicans are all desperate
to lavish praise on him
and do whatever
he orders them to do.
Even his supposed critics,
like his former
Attorney General Bill Barr,
who has a new sham book out
supposedly criticizing
Trump's behavior
and who said,
on Fox News this week,
Trump is unhinged.
-What do you think was
the most alarming
or unsettling moment for you
in the administration?
-It was certainly unsettling
when I went in
to talk to the president
about the election and,
you know,
he was livid and shaking
and, you know,
showed a lot of temper
and yelling.
That was a little unsettling.
But the other thing that was
actually unsettling is later,
when I went in to actually give
him my letter of resignation,
he started talking about how he
had actually won the election
and how the machines were rigged
and that he was actually going
to be there for another term
and he was very confident
of that.
And I just felt this showed
a detachment from reality
that was stunning to me.
-That's what's in your book?
You know he didn't just say
that [bleep] to you, right?
[ Laughter ]
He said it to all of us,
all the time.
Wait, are we all supposed
to be writing books?
[ Laughter ]
Am I going to walk
into Barnes & Noble
and see a tell-all
from my neighbor Bob?
[ Laughter ]
And also, you were stunned,
really?
That's the moment
it finally sunk in for you
that maybe this guy was
a little off, right at the end?
[ Laughter ]
You're like a person who stopped
watching "Game of Thrones"
because it was too violent
in the second-to-last episode.
"I don't know, when The Hound
was fighting The Mountain,
I just thought,
'That's enough for me.'"
[ Laughter ]
But just to illustrate the point
that Trump is still very much
the leader of the GOP,
even Barr,
who is now trying to cash in
with a [bleep] tell-all,
said, in an interview this week,
that, despite Trump's
supposedly stunning detachment
from reality,
he'd still vote for Trump
over a Democrat in 2024.
-If he is the nominee
and your choice is
Donald Trump or whoever's
running on the Democratic side,
would you vote for him?
-Because I believe that the
greatest threat to the country
is the progressive agenda being
pushed by the Democratic Party,
it's inconceivable to me
that I wouldn't vote
for the Republican nominee.
-So, even if he lied
about the election
and threatened democracy,
as you write in your book,
better than a Democrat?
-It's hard to project
what the facts are going
to turn out to be
three years hence,
but as of now,
it's hard for me to conceive
that I wouldn't vote
for the Republican nominee.
-So then, why should we care
about anything you have to say?
Trump's detached from reality,
but you'd still support him
for president?
You're like a cop who gets
a fax from the Zodiac Killer
and says, "This guy's a sicko,
but he'd be
a great math teacher."
[ Laughter ]
Interviewing this charlatan
is such a waste of air time.
Don't help him plug
his dumb book.
There are any number
of other books
that deserve more attention.
If I had a book,
that'd be a better use
of your time.
Oh, wait, I do.
I have a brand-new
children's book called...
[ Laughter ]
My son Axel said it was great
and it's not like he ever lies.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Bleep ]
On the one hand,
Biden is handling the situation
very much how you'd hope
and expect --
soberly and with restraint.
On the other hand,
Trump and his supporters
are just randomly
pitching crazy ideas
for escalating the conflict,
like Fox host Jesse Watters,
who had a retired
lieutenant general on his show
and started just
spitballing reckless ideas
for how other countries
could get involved militarily.
-See if you think
this is a proper idea.
What if we started
distracting the Russians
and made them a little nervous?
What if we had the Japanese
stir up a little trouble
on their eastern flank?
What if we sent some naval
assets into the Black Sea?
Just say, "Hey, you know,
we're protecting Turkey,
our NATO ally."
What if, you know,
we scrambled a few jets
in the Baltics or something?
Something to make the Russians,
maybe, think twice
and take their eye off the ball
a little bit.
-Do you think you're
in a pitch meeting
for the new Steven Seagal movie?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Seagal ]
Tell me what you have, Jesse.
[ As Watters ]
Eastern flank, scramble jets,
naval assets,
stirred up trouble.
[ As Seagal ]
That's very good, Jesse.
[ Laughter ]
The only problem is the budget
for this film
is only $45.
[ Laughter ]
In what possible world
does anyone think
the best path forward
with Vladimir Putin is
to just [bleep] round with him?
[ Laughter ]
If you have a rabid raccoon
in the corner of your garage,
you call animal control,
but I bet you could get someone
on Fox News to say --
[ As Watters ]
"No! What you want to do is
set up a bunch of firecrackers
to freak it out!
[ Laughter ]
And then,
when it's all confused,
you run in dressed
like a giant squirrel and say,
'Come with me
if you want to live!'
[ Laughter ]
And then, when it runs out,
surprise,
you got a second rabid raccoon
you bought on the black market
and now, they have to fight.
Bang, boom, problem solved!
[ Laughter ]
Russia's invasion of Ukraine
is an unfathomable tragedy
that has resulted
in a dire humanitarian crisis
and what we need to do right now
to help the Ukrainian people is
find a path forward toward
dialogue and de-escalation
to end the conflict
as quickly as possible.
What we don't need
are reckless ideas
that would escalate
the conflict,
from people who have no idea
what they're talking about,
like former presidents
whose brains are...
-Rusting and rotting.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.